[Music]
samuel leeds is britain's most notorious
multi-millionaire property investor
best-selling author and founder of a
leading property education company
with hundreds of success students
carving their way to financial freedom
using his cutting-edge strategies
samuel is regarded as the ultimate
renegade property investor
in this year's eviction the stakes have
been raised big time
with the winner receiving the keys to
the kingdom by getting a life-changing
prize
of a whole week's one-to-one mentoring
in their own
financial freedom challenge more drama
more heartbreak and more action as
candidates battle it out to be the 2020
winner of
the eviction we had over 500 people
applied to be on the eviction
we've got 10 candidates that are part of
the process
let's see what happens this is crazy
you're evicted
previously on the eviction i'm i'm
stressed
i'm stressed on their behalf i'm
confident we're going to win
you've got till then to sell that deal i
would recommend you sell it tonight and
you get the money in your bank tonight
i've just secured a deal in warrington
tonight's gonna be
hard two minutes to go why prolong the
sale
the night yeah and some of them are
already an interest that's
huge they haven't got the hunger that
we've got the strong team
i don't know who's going to win this
this could go either which way so
i'm very sorry but you're a victim
you've got 50 hours they don't really
know what they're doing
two dollars from postcodes half a mile
away because i'll pack up and go home
like i know i will because it doesn't
bother me you're going to present to me
and show me the lease option agreement
contract signed yes
yes it is well done that just came out
of nowhere
honestly not even one of them can close
the door that you've secured
during the challenge
[Laughter]
looking forward to the first ever
eviction wedding now lads so let's join
samuel at his gaffe to hear about
challenge number three
police option agreements congratulations
welcome to
challenge three challenge three the
theme
is lease option agreements
so the lease option agreement for anyone
doesn't know bother by show of hands has
anyone secured a lease option agreement
before
nobody okay so you might know what it is
you might not have any idea at least
option agreement is when you buy a
property now
so you're gonna be buying a property
this week by the way but you pay for it
later and then in the meantime it could
be five seven years time
you're going to benefit from the monthly
cash flow you're going to benefit from
the capital appreciation
and your challenge is going to be around
lease option agreements i'm going to set
the challenge afterwards but first
this is the lease option boot camp so i
want to take you through
a to z exactly what a lease option
agreement is
where to find them how to secure them
and how to secure them fast because
the idea is that you're going to be
securing properties with
no money this week once you've got
through the training you're not going to
be on your own
you're going to have me helping you
through the process you're also
going to have my ears and eyes with you
at all times in the forms of
anthony coming up and dave give me a
hand your man
so anthony very experienced property
investor you know from the last
challenge
dave very experienced property investor
they've both gone through my property
investors academy
um you won the eviction you've got a
lease option agreement dave right
through at the moment right
right okay so he's gone throughout the
moment so these guys know what they're
talking about they're going to be with
you
i'm going to be with you virtually we're
going to be walking you through the
process and helping you over the coming
challenge okay thanks so much guys
okay so lease option boot camp here we
go so there's a difference between
assets and liabilities
an asset is something that appreciates
in value and gives you money
a liability is something that
depreciates in value and doesn't give
you any money
we are encouraged by the tv the media
even the banks to buy liabilities
that we can't afford and often to buy
them but pay for them later so for
instance when i was buying my hot tub
i was told do you want to buy it now and
pay for it in a couple years
that's not a smart move because it's
going to go down in value and in two
years i've still got to pay for it
if you buy a property that's in a
trending area and you say i'll buy it
now but i'll pay for it in five years
what's going to happen is over that five
years you're going to benefit from the
capital appreciation
but you're also going to benefit from
five years worth of rent
who on earth would give you their house
though for free who enough would say
yeah you can pay for it in five years
well the answer
is number one people that don't need the
money now
maybe they've inherited the property and
then i don't need the money now and you
say i'll buy off you in five years they
don't care they just want to get rid of
it
or secondly people that are in negative
equity meaning that the value of their
house
is worth less than the debt on their
house
they want to sell the house but they've
got no equity in it
they could sell it for full asking price
and they'd have no money in their pocket
so you'll say well if i bought it off
you tomorrow for full asking price
you'd have no money in your pocket
anyway how about this i'll buy it off
you for full asking price
but i'll buy it in five years time but
right now i'll take it off your hands
you're going to benefit from the capital
appreciation you're going to benefit
from the cash flow
that's the lease option agreement 2007
it was bought for 77 grand
now it's on the market for 72 950 and it
can't sell is there equity in that yes
or no no
no there's not and here's the thing that
property has been on the market
for three years he can't sell it's on
for 72 950.
chances are they bought that in
well they bought in 2007 for 77 grand
guaranteed the mortgage outstanding on
that is probably about 70 grand
so why are they trying to sleep with 72
because they need to pay off the
mortgage
so they can't drop it
but it's been on the market for years so
if we
went around their house hey pet
you're trying to sell your house for 72
grand and you can't it's been on the
market for three years
what's your mortgage out standing on it
oh 72.
all right cool how about this i'll just
take on the property i'll buy off you
for 72 grand
but i'll buy off you in five years time
to give the market chance to recover
and right now what your mortgage
payments are 100 quid a month i'll take
on the mortgage payments and then i'll
stick a tenant in myself and i'll
take responsibility of it they give it
to you
you pay the hundred pound a month you
rent it out for 450 you're making a few
hundred quid a month
but then you're going to get all the
capital appreciation because we all know
that greater manchester is going to boom
in the next few years
that's the lease option agreement right
there i would be phoning that agent and
going hey
i wanna i'm in the area tonight i'll
come around oh i can't do a viewing
tonight
because we close at five could i meet
the owner direct
great i'll meet the owner direct i'm
there tonight bang
and then pitch them on a lease option
agreement person who views the most
houses in the next two days wins
to keep the candidates on their toes
samuel ushers them all outside in
nothing but shorts and a t-shirt while
he smugly tells them how long they've
got to complete the challenge excellent
so ready for challenge
three you've had the lease option boot
camp training you guys know what a lease
option is you know how to find a vendor
you've never done it before but your
challenge is going to be
you've got 50 hours which means that
we're going to meet back
on wednesday at 7 00 p.m
at my house and when you come back
you're gonna present to me
and show me the lease option agreement
contract signed
that you've secured during the challenge
now i'm going to be looking at who
whoever's got the best lease option
agreement deal
if you've got multiple deals that's
great but i'm going to be looking at
whoever's
who's got the strongest lease option
agreement and that team will be the
winning team
the losing team it might be that the
whole team
is evicted because we're only going to
have three
remaining candidates after this
challenge which will be going into the
finals
so we need to either the teams out a
little bit because at the moment we've
got
lawton and
two people and then there's four of you
so david
as your team was the winning team could
you please let me know
out of your team who's the weakest link
and we're going to kick them out of your
team so who's the who's the weakest
uh i think just personally what i can
walk off i'm going to
go for fast
absolutely fuming very fast you're over
on to
leighton's team great so now the team's
even
evenly spread you've got a team of three
a team of three
you've got 50 hours to come back show me
the contract
of the lease option agreement you
secured i'm going to be around to help
over zoom in over the phone over the
next couple of days
you're going to have david you're going
to have anthony they're going to be ears
and eyes
50 hours starts now off you go
[Applause]
so fast first of all welcome to the team
thank you
the winning team i think it will be very
productive if i go away
find some leads send that to you guys
and by the time you get to your
destination you have a few people to
kind of go through
so the teams are 50 hours to secure a
lease option agreement which is not
ambitious at all saying that in the last
eviction anthony hannah
ricky and lord john rayball secured
nearly 300
000 pounds worth in only 48 hours so
no pressure guys seven o'clock we're in
liverpool
with one team member down these option
agreements
as you just mentioned just one team
member down there's two of us orion
couldn't come
which i am genuinely devastated about
yeah i mean
i've personally been on the team that's
had the least amount of people
throughout this whole yeah
uh eviction challenge and then for to
leave after
getting past the eviction stage i just
think wow
you know it is a letdown for our team
like you said
we've traveled from london up into
liverpool area the north west we're
going to try and find some lease option
agreements
i was driving back last night you was on
the phone all
night booking them appointments did a
great job i think if you just get in
there now
book up the rest of the appointments for
viewings this afternoon and tomorrow
morning
yeah we're just going to smash it
yeah no no i'm not looking to sell a
lease option i'm looking to find or
obtain a lease option
i'm going to go and see him yeah see
what happens look what we've got there
before we get here we'll be open to
offloading them
okay what about a block of flaps
this can do us you can do a small block
of flowers if you like
with those flats made into three events
it's a bit more interesting than a
normal house bigger numbers two or more
god that could be literally that could
be it
you know we could win this now maybe
that's
one one two three we're like a divorce
marriage we were separated at the start
and then we've come together and united
[Laughter]
have been a landlord they're just
stressed out with it they want to get
rid of it
we can come in we can give them the full
asking price at a delayed time so we may
be in five to seven years
but a minute we can take over the
mortgage repayments look after the
upkeep of the property and then put
somebody else in there to rent it
i said do you know anyone she said she's
actually got someone who had a deal fall
through
she's a tired stressed out landlord she
previously had it rented out and it's
empty now so it's costing her money
every month
every month that goes by that there's
not a tenant in there it's costing her
mortgage repayments so
she's gonna have a conversation with us
gonna give her a call back we might be
going up to blackpool today to go and
see this landlord
let's keep it going we've got to keep
getting on the phones and speaking to
people here's a lovely little service
station roundabout and oh cool we're on
the train
if we don't get properties today it's
not going to be good
here i think two dollar from postcodes
half a mile away
yeah coming up here two minutes away
because she gave me
a different postcode to what was on the
head so
[Applause]
well yeah and would you would you ever
consider renting the property oh it used
to be right it's been managed for the
last
12 13 years about it i know you've got
all the properties as well yeah and yeah
is it all in stoke or
insane area
78 purple bricks want to put it on for
85 and i was like
no i haven't gone with them um and
i know around this area then they know
where well
some on the main road are up for 102
don't know how
it's on the main road it's asking places
and
that's true so with bill brick saying 85
yeah you'd probably get eight i was like
i'm sorry i'm really trying to
concentrate but will you stop playing
with the coins in your pocket man
it's driving me bonkers
situation i mean i couldn't offer the
full amount you know and it's
uh you know i just wouldn't like to put
an offensive offer
hello thank you for no worries
um yes well i've got your
do you want me to send i'll take your
image i'll
just exchange both
this is your current conversation with
people that's so often down
um or you can't you're repeating
information or or
you know and confusing the values watch
the evans bought from ebay there
it can tell you the time in 37 different
countries you have the skills to do this
you just need to get your points across
better you need to work out
for are you seriously just jumped on the
phone
while we're talking okay
okay this is my point though because i'm
trying to give you advice i'm trying to
help you with this
and then nobody's listening to me you
know because i'll pack up and go home
like i know i will because it doesn't
bother me you know i've given up my time
to help you
and you guys aren't taking on my advice
so you know i'm not fussed
i will go home like i've got no qualms
with that so take my advice because it's
useful
i think it went well no no no no it
didn't go well
at all mate you just mugged off the
winner of last year's eviction the man
who eats lease options for breakfast
you look like you're in a daydream and
your mate was ringing for a chinese
takeaway
sort of outlawed why don't we call the
agents because they're definitely in a
pinpoint
yeah i was just double checking 4.95 it
has been on hold
um i'm not sure the reason why but it
was park hole for a while
um but yes it would be open to offers
obviously they'd like to get as close to
the full asking as they possibly can but
they would be open to office
okay see if i was to buy it today the
like to be honest like i do want to i
love these guys and credit to them for
stepping up but this is so
boring how can you sell anything to
anyone when you sound like you couldn't
give a toss
get some energy go after it and get the
bloody deal
frankly dave it sounds like you can't be
bothered
decoration really yeah is it on the
market
well you've just got it we've just got
it new so yeah
so yeah um
you formed up to ask what we've got
yeah um with this has just come to us
without the amount of time to do
anything with it we are very interested
in
um maybe doing like a lease option
agreement
if the um personally we might be
interested in that well we always take
over the property now
and in the meantime we'll give the
landlord of the vendor
guaranteed rent and we'll pay the rent
we'll pay the bills cover everything for
them
and the price that they're asking for if
not maybe even a little bit more
we'll be able to pay that but in an
extended period of time
but in the meantime we'll take over
everything this property would work very
great it would work
great for us because that's what you
think they'll be open to we can only ask
a question
yeah you'd have to um is it how many
people are involved in this property in
terms of the children
it's just for one person oh is it yeah
that's what i've done meanwhile anyway
right well that's just one person well
that's good because in like a nutshell
i mean you deal with investors often as
i imagine
what would be looking doing is taking
this on like sort of a guaranteed rent
for say five years
agreeing a sale on it and then paying
for it in five years
obviously the fees that you get for
selling it you'll get them
we'll renovate it put a tenant in it and
then if you do lettings you do lettings
as well yeah we do all that
yeah it wouldn't be our decision though
yeah of course you have to be a seller
yeah
yeah course course but that's kind of
like our idea behind what he was looking
for on this type of property
i mean it's a decent problem put that
forward to him um
well if you need to speak with our
office yeah
even if it's if it's more helpful we can
do a three-way conversation if they come
to meet us
or even if they want to call us directly
well yeah again
stick it in an email yeah i don't think
that we're going to get an answer on
this in the time that we need
personally but this is a great example
of where these opportunities can work
out because if they don't need the money
now and they sell for it now i think we
can delay that in five years
and then maybe give them say hundred
pound a month extra yeah that might be
attractive for them yeah but it
this type of property definitely does
work in that scenario definitely
right we've got another point anyway so
let's go then we are off to our next
property viewing which is in blackpool
yes get in the heart of the north the
jewel of seaside tourism
with a crack addict on every corner and
a jeremy kyle contestant on every street
welcome to blackpool properties under
the hammer
well potentially because this can be
split into two flats
yeah give him the ground floor got your
agreement and you've got at least you've
got one rental property
he can you know keep that property up
downstairs and then eventually when he
decides is that enough that's when you
take the option and get two flats
yeah yeah so you're talking about the
kitchen splitting the kitchen put it
back from the kitchen
yeah i mean ultimately what we could do
if he did do it
we could convert it for him i could
agree on sales say i could agree a sale
today yeah i could convert
it getting back in pay him say in five
seven years but also give him like um
like a retainer everywhere so you could
earn say
you know 100 a month yeah to get a brand
new
one-bed apartment yeah
plus more because it'd be worth more
then i'll spend all money
and look after it yeah so here's a
hands-on approach in a way
he'll still be a landlord in essence but
it'll be a hands-on approach
so what'd you think after that then
you've done well
you couldn't have done any better so
hopefully but we're getting closer and
closer now obviously to
hopefully try and get some more yeah i
think it was a i think it was a great
meeting i think it was
i think i honestly think it was really
good the way that we can
work it so that this deal doesn't just
benefit or selfishly like it
that deal genuinely benefited them all
right so i've just had a
text message from the next person when
we're heading over there shall i
look for properties or we're going to
get the the message written up for her
to send over for a dad goes to bed like
she said yeah get the message written up
that's
most important this is our strongest
lead so far and we've built up the most
amount of rapport with these
this young couple these two so we need
to do what we say when we're gonna do it
slight disclaimer here the properties in
blackpool are mega cheap this is true
but as with many
old seaside tourist towns in the uk the
clientele can be notoriously difficult
and there are a lot of social economic
problems all over the place
two sides of the same street can be the
difference between old kent road and
mayfair
so don't get lured in by comparing house
prices on rightmove
unless you know the area well if you
need a helping hand to invest in
blackpool drop me an email
crackdown at blackpool.bin
you can buy it off of you for a much
higher price
and then the prices went up by we can
split that money so i could say it's
going to buy
50 000 i will take from it 25 and i'll
give you an extra 25 as well as the
money that you want for it now
what like family complications no she
just doesn't want to rent a shot
to sell her oh she so you're probably
more open to that
other options whereas your sister kind
of wants cash
yeah completely take over it we'll put
we'll
do some more cosmetic work stops you
doing all right like we'll do a bit more
so it makes him look more appealing and
we'll get good tenants we want quality
tenants to look after your property
and so that means a little bit of
cosmetic we will do
we'll sort the mortgage the bills
everything you won't even have nothing
to do with the property you just every
month
everything we paid and if the money is
right we can even send you over a little
retention fee if the money is there for
us to do say if we said
we could buy it for one three five
mm-hmm
yeah in seven years as a grand total but
say in the five years we could
buy it so that your sister was out so
she has to wait a little longer for
her money but this is the the best bit
about it it's like
like he was mentioning the prices are
going up so if this house is worth more
than that
in five years time which it will be we
can split the difference on that
rise well don't mate i just want to say
congratulations i felt like you did well
there
you spoke well he spoke confident
halfway there i felt
perfect personally i'm halfway there
it's it's amazing from this morning when
they did the first viewing
and to now it's a complete change that
they've listened they've grown
they've developed they're they're
working as a team now which we're
working as individually
they're both not interrupting each other
they're both talking separately
and they're also picking up on each of
them says and then re
reinforcing the situation in a lease
option where it's going to be a win for
them we're waiting for the person that's
selling the property
and eventually win for you okay we're
currently in manchester
alongside we're here for our last tenant
of the
night last landlord actually never
answered then
very last minute they popped out of
nowhere and it was actually tenant came
out she said the landlord's not here so
give us the number
i'm gonna try and contact him now it's
getting late it's
all right just turned nine still not got
a lease option agreement yet hopefully
tomorrow we'll have a
bad day we've only got half a day it is
what it is
honestly i love these guys but why is
their energy so low this year it's like
no one cares
so that's um that's another property so
the tenant's actually in at 18 years
and uh yeah that sounds good yeah yeah
very well so if you could get in touch
with the
this this landlord and the other one
i'll try and get the two few installed
today
all right brilliant all right thank you
very much
yeah i'll speak to you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell is this cameraman doing
this that your option is possibly a good
one well as mentioned on the phone we
we would take a property on fully manage
it right take it off your hands
completely and we'll pay off the monthly
mortgage payments
right and an addition on top of that
okay something that we can agree on
right and so we're both happy with now
[Music]
obviously that's one of the issues
because the mortgage payment is so small
a bit like your forehead 109 yeah so
that edition
is what what really what edition would
you be looking at
[Applause]
what's happening what's happening what's
happening what's happening is we're in
conversation
um you know there's different type of
individuals there's individuals who will
they impulse uh you know uh people they
will make a quick decision and there are
those they're very analytical so
she's very very very keen this is a very
very big opportunity
we got quite a few possible lease option
agreements
but she needs to obviously look over
with her husband um and i'm confident
within the next
you know so a few hours to maybe uh you
know the next uh
a few days will definitely be some
business with her but yeah
list option baby okay so i left the copy
there so she can read it and we'll send
her
the draft copy and she just said she's
got another property down the road
that she wants to sell as well and a
couple of flats as well
properly and she wants to all of them on
a lease option
so there's a good good potential here
the task is to secure a lease option
oh i would be sending her across all the
information exactly like you stated
and then ringing her off just ring her
off and say so
really appreciate you meeting us i've
sent everything across
you're gonna speak to your husband at
six o'clock like you said uh
just to confirm you're happy with
everything in principle
um you know and almost get her to say
like
yes i'm happy to go ahead with it
obviously she needs to speak to her
husband yes it might fall over when she
speaks to a husband
we just want that confirmation a bit
stressful at the minute
i've got two deals one in telford one in
stoke but i'm just gonna have to do it
so we've just been out for some more
viewing this morning um
i'm trying to get the guys organized
about what they've done yesterday
they've got
lots of deals going on you know spoke to
lots of motivated
landlords that are interested in lease
options
but i'm going to be honest these deals
should be closing and not one of these
guys could do it honestly
not even one of them could close the
door
what makes you think this might be a
lease option i think
uh the price that they bought if it was
over inflated so this is the property
that they brought already
when the house the new estate was built
yep and now we're looking to sell them
that's correct
four bedrooms attached house um just
under the side of town
fantastic that's great so you're not
dependent on the sale of this property
to carry on i'll still make money
fantastic what what do you think the
lawyers you are you you you owe the city
van berman that we get along
and you know um probably 170 170 yeah so
if we were to offer you something like
you know 150 you know that's something
that you consider
no you wouldn't cover the bills it
wouldn't cover the bills
um i reckon mortgage only probably about
a 300 pound 400 point
mortgage for nearly 500 nearly 500
that's cool um all right i mean
if we were to do this i mean we possibly
can offer you um
the asking price in fact we can offer
you the asking price um
what we would need though we would need
about 46 months to have the market to
recover
okay so that's the second option now why
would you do that because it can be a
win-win for you
um we can do you know a few things
we can give you the asking price in the
36 months but from now till then we can
obviously take full
you know uh chartered property so we
cover the we copy the mortgage
we cover all the overheads um and you
can get the full asking price then
um and you know if there's anything on
top you know we might be able to you
know even squeeze something on top
just to incentivize it so overall if you
look at the deal completely you know
it'd be more financially
uh viable for you how does that sound
so just to break it down um what it
means is we'll fully manage the property
and we'll pay you your mortgage payments
plus um
an additional premium on top
for the three years and but we would
agree a price now
and purchase it after three years to the
price that we've agreed does that make
sense
yeah how does that sound
i'm not gonna go wild and make a
decision right now yeah
um because that sounds absolutely
fantastic yeah you know
i like the idea of it fantastic um it
means i don't have to pay it
exactly what the question is the first
question that comes to mind is
then what do you guys get out of it
do i stay in the house for three years
nope we will take over
it so we would obviously i mean that's
the way we can obviously make money yeah
you know because honestly investors so
investors yeah uh i mean there are some
investors
it's just a win-win for them they won't
have to make money uh we don't operate
that way that's the reason why we've
obviously been very
you're not good at what we do because we
add value to you and we add value to us
because we know obviously you know most
times together asking brexit property
you know you struggle yeah so we can
obviously secure that for you don't give
you no overhead worried about paying two
mortgages don't worry about
any maintenance if you know if you
choose to rent it out you don't have to
worry about
the tenants in there what they do so we
alleviate all of that stress
and we give you the money that you want
and of course we're building a
relationship who knows where it's going
to live
so what we're going to get out of it is
we're obviously going to get any
you know any money that we can make in
the rent so let's just say roughly it's
average for about 2 300 japan
um it's not a lot but it adds up so yeah
so that's pretty much
what we're going to make really i'm
going to build something big i'm sure
you're going to have friends
you've been in the army i'm sure you
know a lot of individuals will have
houses probably in the same city mission
as you
if we treat you properly you can refer
to them so yeah you can obviously speak
to her come out to us
later on today and hopefully fill some
business together
are we gonna are we gonna handshakes
this time we're gonna do it look at that
yes yes here well thank you very much
this is how you close the normally now
baby nice so tell me what happened
so what happened is we haven't got a
football agreement yes get in
textbook by evan and you know what he
sounded like the only guy who cared when
pitching to a landlord good job mate
so said he all um seems like a good one
he said the lm
messaged me now his email i sent it over
in principal and he said he's happy to
agree in principle
right now and then go from there started
to realize mistakes we should have
started doing this from the start of the
morning came with a new approach this
morning our first phone call
in my new approach he wasn't open to it
at all
but from my training from being around
samuel the team
the environment just it was it was
wicked new
that's what we said though because we
spent the whole day doing one strategy
looking for people
potentially wanting to sell their
products tomorrow yesterday i know but
it's good though because
what we might have done is exhausted all
the opportunities or leads that we might
have had for the sale
like people want to sell their house and
now we're looking for people who want to
rent it
landlords renting their house might have
other properties that they might think
actually that idea might work
nice to meet you well this is the first
house i've got to show you perfect
um now it's not quite as it should be
yes
um but we're willing to do a deal on
maybe discounting the rent on a
long-term rental
is this the one that you said that the
landlord didn't have the fund to sort of
bring you up to standards
and i said i can do that for him that's
right give him a guaranteed event with
the option to buy in say five or seven
years
yeah that's so we can talk about the
details of that
once you've had to look around and see
if it suits you
so incentives and we're okay
[Music]
you know on the face of it yeah no it's
nice no problem at all
it's a decent house it's just not quite
as it should be yeah
so if you're willing to do the the
difference
spend the few quid it needs we're happy
to do the you know i've spotted a
landlord he's happy to do you
a cheap rent the problems you always
this is where you need to get the
expensive makeup out because yeah
you've got to do the proper good
tweaking yeah um
i mean it's a little bit tired the
kitchen but it's passable
it's probably got another
giant if they're actually all right they
just need cleaning up
they just need screwing in properly and
then change these handles
you know it just needs a good cleaning
it's a win-win situation isn't it like
if he's not got the time or the budget
to bring this property up to standard
we do that's what we're looking for
that's exactly what we're looking for
this is really good i'm feeling really
good about this one but
see when anything's the next one it's
not far away perfect that's probably
we'll follow you down just
look at which is brilliant i mean if
you've got any more that's like this
yeah or there needs a little bit more
work i'm open to seeing them
so after asking about the rental and the
the demand in the area i mean look down
the road
you've got one there that's let agreed
you've got more further up the street
and you've got some over that way that
have let agreed as well so the demand is
definitely there so i'm excited about
this one
so i'll show you inside and you can look
down
let's see what you think
it smells a bit but yeah yeah
nothing that new carpets about the mix
this car has been in a good few years
we've probably got these in about five
years ago
there's still twelve intensive purposes
yeah right new really yeah the ovens
just needs to clean yeah
this is not this is the money only needs
to be spent on it the only money that
needs spending on here really
is a good lipstick and makeup job
yesterday it's all about the decorating
probably yeah to shift it up another
notch we do some nice feature walls
things like that
make it look really nice when you go
upstairs you'll see it's a very plain
bathroom
yeah to get it to that next level we
need to do a while in here
yeah and the wow i would say is the
bathroom yeah like a new flooring in
some nice house around the shower in
bathroom
yeah probably tylenol that's what i
normally go for yeah yeah and then
in the front room a nice fire suite
simple little things like that
he's looking at off-loading them slowly
obviously we know why
so if i can agree a price with him today
with the option to buy it in say five
seven years but give him a guaranteed
rental through and look after the
meeting to the property
and get a tenant in there obviously
we'll work with that we've been
letting agent getting the tenants in
there as well you know this is a a
win-win
it's a nice property you think that we
will get us anything pretty quick once
we've got it
to refer to how we mentioned you bring
it to me
nice and pretty yeah you're nice and
pretty
perfect the maintenance you take over
everything you're responsible for
everything yeah don't think as if the
boiler's not working oh no don't
piss me out like that you rent this for
i don't know five six seven years
whatever we agree
you can you can get the better rent and
keep the difference and just make sure
you pay us the
deal the figures we agree that sounds
good yes
get in son that sounds really positive
your gross yields you've got a good deal
there you've got a good deal
i'm happy about
you don't have to spend you don't spend
anything you're going to get this
15 15 50 you're gonna get that gate
fixed i'll fix the gate i've already got
that signed i've got to be on the count
for that
they're always rented out we could get
the other one rented out
but yeah let's go sure elbow bump
come on that's how we secure a deal in
2020 don't leave him hanging come on
elbow bump oh that's awkward
it's not the same second time round is
it it's like when you've got a repeater
joke
let's get back to london we're in a rush
deals agreed lease options signed
but who'll be signing off in the
boardroom
excellent so you're back on time that's
good you didn't have long you had like
50 hours to go and secure
a lease option agreement what did you
think you did the lease option boot camp
you received the short sharp training on
how to go and secure a property with no
money and then you were given 50 hours
to go and get a deal did you think you
would
secure a lease option agreement
absolutely
you knew you would you knew you were
gonna yeah
and you didn't just secure one you
secured multiple deals
so you know it's fabulous also um this
team over here
what happened with auen i don't know
actually i have i feel like
maybe for me i feel like maybe the
pressure was maybe just too much ever
so faz what did you contribute to this
because
lawson found the agent laughed and
secured the deals
i mean yeah he did
with his with his deals i was getting
getting a lot of strong leads
like many of the people in the room i
didn't manage to secure any i was
getting very close
i got my pictures of change now just
about the last minute too late
um i feel like i was just ready to i got
my picture ready i
would have started to convert yeah um
but it's not about what could have
would have happened it's about what did
and ultimately it doesn't look like
you'd actually did much on this
challenge
i think it'll be really difficult for me
to say you know your team was the losing
team i don't think there was a losing
team
but looking at the deals and the quality
of the deals contracts signed
no money down you know really good deals
you know cash flowing positive capital
appreciation expected
i mean faz if i'm honest from what i've
seen of the footage
um it looks to me like the weight was
all on lawton's shoulders
yeah so in that case um you know i think
you've smashed out the park
but within your team with the fact that
lawson you know was
was the leader and did all the deals um
i'm sadly gonna have to say
you're evicted it's the right the right
decision thank you welcome
lawton you're safe all right did you
yes of course i'm really happy to make
it this far
and today i learned so much i said to
lauren up here like i expected
to not get past the first stage then the
second stage i hardly knew anything
and to be here today i generally don't
feel emotional about what's happening
there right start new journey look at
him look
i mean i mean andrea if i'm honest from
what i've seen with the footage and
speaking to
speaking to anthony would you say it'd
be fair to say that you're probably the
weakest out of the three
definitely not really
really yeah
and if they tell the truth they'll tell
you
yeah i think entry should be affected
because well look i mean he's the
weakest link 100
okay yeah i mean i can sit here and give
you my opinion of this my opinion of
that
i mean we only brought fox to the table
we haven't even brought opinions or i
had you know a hotel upgrade
for a list option i had a number one uh
grade four seven eight we're not
bringing those things because it's not
solidified
all you bringing to the table is facts
the facts is i have two deals
you have zero deals okay you want to
argue that you had half
okay i'll give you half that's one and a
half you have half he has one
numbers don't lie i was driving all of
the way i still have got recorded on my
phone
i have middle of the 200 holes that's
recorded how do you got that
okay okay okay that's fine let's talk
about let's talk about viewings books
i've booked 11 viewings we've come to
four just to accumulate some of yours
we viewed several of mine like this is
facts let's just say we give you the
deals how many viewers did you have
two andre it's hard to argue with
because what what evans has said is even
if you were part responsible for that
for that one deal
evan still found it so it's kind of half
a deal so you've got one and a half
one half had one in preston where the
agent on the phone said
i i want to work with you that's why we
went and i spoke to them
yeah and they're they're happy to work
with me so does that count as a deal so
i've got a deal and a half as well
if that's the case anthony was there i
think i have to bring anthony in
and get his perspective but anthony you
were there the whole time
yes endri is saying that he was the
strongest contestant
i don't think you were the strongest
contestant um i do think out of the
three were the weakest
because even today i know right now for
a fact there's things that i've coached
you on to do
that i guarantee you've not done the
amount of times
that's been wasted on opportunities that
could have been followed up
you know and you're not the only person
that's that's victim of this
but the other guys did close deals and
you didn't and you had
two amazing opportunities that if you
close the deals your team would have won
the task
okay so endrit it's really difficult for
me now because
anthony was there he's a very trusted
advisor of mine
everybody's saying that you were the
weakest link i have to make evictions
i'm very sorry we'll stay in touch but
you are evicted
this is crazy i've learned so much um
i'm gonna be i've got leads pending so
tomorrow i'm gonna be just go
on the phones closing these deals that
are left and and
yeah it's not stopping me it's just
pushing me to work two times harder
this house that we're staying in right
now it's actually an infamous house what
are you doing in the roof
oh that's sick i'm gonna put the
pressure on real hard now
they've got a refurbishment challenge
with a small budget
they're going to have to go and find a
tenant from scratch leave the capital
letter stone furniture
manager bro who enemies the best friends